what do you think of John McCain I have
a whole CD of Ron Paul songs my favorite
they're like little kids each of my
songs are like my children I love him to
do well so he's our president man Ron
Paul from Texas
he's a president man the funky number
the chorus is hold for America Paul for
America and it's about Ron Paul and the
goals for this week is to hopefully show
the world that we can take our country
back and we can't have liberty and
freedom like our forefathers intended
been delighted to me you know to see
their eyes and just go yeah yeah you
know a brother sister whatever give him
a hug to take our freedom back take our
rights back my name is BJ Lawson I am
the congressional candidate the Ron Paul
Republican congressional nominee in
North Carolina's fourth District the
biggest goal is kicking off a movement
this is the beginning this is not the
end and what the biggest impact is going
to be is are these thousands of people
this 1012 thousand person group going
out into our communities and making a
difference
talking about what it means to have a
good federal government that lives
within its means and its mandate out in
our local communities to educate people
about the Constitution and how important
it is the general appreciation of love
for all things freedom
I'll write in Ron Paul why cuz he's
fighting for our freedoms he's the only
let if you vote for the lesser of two
evils are still voting for evil Ron Paul
that there's just no turning backwards
so it's right now it's still Ron Paul I
want to see his numbers huge you know I
don't want to vote for a lesser I don't
want I don't want to have my name really
associated with something I don't
believe in simple as that
I'll probably write in Ron Paul because
he stands for freedom he's against the
IRS and the banking system
they're both frauds honestly I've really
given up on presidential politics it's
so difficult to run a national campaign
without the Nashua thout the mainstream
media fawning at your feet it's really
difficult even to run a statewide
campaign I'm planning on voting for
Chuck Baldwin Constitution Party because
he agrees with Ron Paul a voting for Bob
Barr mainly because he's the only one
left in the presidential contention that
really represents freedom Liberty
smaller government smaller taxes less
taxes and general constitutional
principle yes I wouldn't be here if I
didn't think it could we need to take it
over sure sure
uh-huh a process of tearing it to pieces
and rebuilding it I doubt it I work for
them they're losers
they treat us like dogmeat I don't know
and honestly I don't look at my role as
being focused on saving the Republican
Party it's saving our constitutional
republic No
now I'm gonna keep telling people about
the truth I learned in the last two
years that we can't take up anything and
I believe it and it's worth the fight
because I have to how could it not with
each one of these people here at this
rally today being one in a million and I
do believe that including yourself every
person that's here is really really
special oh of course I'll go to my grave
with this belief I expected it will and
looking at our campaign as an example we
have grassroots organizers from across
the political spectrum why I truly hope
that they find the Libertarian Party
because it truly is a party of principle
it's a party personal responsibility I
hope that they find the party you know
we all have to be united if our goal is
to to restore the Constitution keep the
Constitution and keep our country
sovereign but we have to unite whether
we agree on every little issue or not
our issue is Liberty that's what we have
to unite around